hey y'all movie retrospective although
on today's show i think i didn't
entirely real i mean i kind of realized
this when i put it in the poll
um
when i put it in the poll this was like
shutter had just added it so i was like
really excited about it so this is
actually a series uh from 1980 like a
british tv series called hammer house of
horror
so
i mean i think i realized it was a
series but i didn't realize
how long it was going to take me to
watch it because there's 13 episodes and
each episode is like 52 53 minutes so
this is essentially like 13 hours worth
of entertainment but i persevered uh tom
didn't see all of them no i saw some of
them but uh but i actually like watched
all of them like over the course of a
couple of days and uh i don't i thought
that i had seen this when i was a kid
but a lot of it wasn't real familiar so
maybe it was another one i'm saying
because i love horror anthologies
um and there were a lot of them like
coming out around this time period and
even like in the us and stuff like that
i mean obviously we have like the big
hitters over here like twilight zone and
we have one thriller which i kind of
feel like was that boris karloff i don't
know i don't really want to say what
that is but i don't know gallery yeah
and night galleries actually i was just
going to say night gallery is actually
one of my favorite and some of the
stories in this kind of reminded me of
night gallery a little bit yeah it is
very night gallery-esque um but the
thing about it though is that because
it's hammer i think pretty much all of
them are set in like um you know the
modern day or what was modern in 1980.
you all have boobs too but
they pretty much do they pretty
much they all have nudity and now now
here
right off the bat i'm gonna tell you
guys it's not the same epic nature of
boob and boo bit bubbism that happened
in the hammer movies you know those
girls were [ __ ] off the charts these
are more kind of like
i would say kind of b and c stringer
type actresses you know what i mean
you think yeah a lot of them they were
good looking but they weren't like some
of the knockouts from the movies well i
kind of feel like by 1980
um i mean hammer came back like later on
fairly recently but i kind of feel like
this was um you know hammers kind of
like last hurrah yeah was doing this
series uh i think it was for itv which
was like the rival the bbc at the time
they're doing they're trying to do what
hammer does they're just doing yeah
they're doing it in a slightly updated
fashion and maybe they're trying to
maybe they were kind of saying that
those uh
you know [ __ ] victorian [ __ ]
bustiers and the [ __ ] titties up
around the ears and [ __ ] oh that was all
passe oh that's just too sexist we can't
have that anymore just take your clothes
off
i don't know i kind of feel like they
were more trying i think they were
trying something different like we're
just going to do something like modern
they were trying to modernize it a lot
yeah so it but still boobs because you
know yeah it was kind of a hippie vibe
too it wasn't so 60s it wasn't swimming
in 60 yeah so it's very very i mean it
came out in 1980 like early 1980s which
very seventies they had a couple they
had that one uh they had like some
decent witches and [ __ ] in it you know i
mean one which episode was pretty good
yeah that was like the first one was
like the first one that was pretty good
um and interestingly i think that i
recognized because i watched you know a
lot of british movies and british tv and
stuff back in the day so i think i
recognized every single [ __ ]
actor yes
seriously every one of them made a [ __ ]
ton of movies too they did and like tv
shows yeah and so it's just kind of like
so the whole experience of me watching
this series was just kind of like hey
it's that guy and hey it's that woman he
had to do to play dim from [ __ ] uh uh
yeah i couldn't believe i saw him he was
like in the second one yeah uh dennholm
elliott was in one which is probably my
favorite episode he was actually the dad
in brimston and treacle yeah yeah uh as
well but i mean he was he was in a [ __ ]
ton of stuff yeah i know you class up
the joint all the time you just have him
around
and that dude was like the british
version of burgess meredith you just you
know pull burgess meredith out put him
in the movie like i said let him class
up the job yeah that didn't class have a
joy a little bit but yeah so these are
these were cool because i mean obviously
just like with any anthology series um
you're gonna get some that are stronger
than others but these are all
surprisingly decent these were all
really worth watching i think there was
like a couple
uh that were standouts um but all of
them were were pretty damn good i put it
on par with
with um night gallery although night
gallery was eerier a lot weirders at
certain times but
close yeah so i'm just saying like if
you if you liked the hammer horror
movies this is essentially like 13 short
hammer films but said in the modern day
so they're not like kind of gothic
really um there were a couple of them
had that sort of had gothic
trappings to them yeah they didn't have
the gothic look but yeah but most of
them were kind of storytelling was kind
of kind of like yeah because i think
that like some of the directors and
writers it was it looked like pretty
much the same pool i think most of them
was just directed it was like three
different dudes um and they had done uh
you know some other hammer movies in the
past uh i think one of them had done
satanic rites of dracula and one did
like dracula 80 1972 so you know so if
you like like hammer movies want to see
like a more modern take on them they
still have a hammer vibe but they're
modern yeah and i kind of feel like
you'll probably really dig this too if
you're into like the amicus
horror anthology movies because i really
dig those as well yeah i love like
anthology type of stuff so let's kind of
go through all the episodes and when we
get to ones that i think are the best
ones
then we'll talk like a little bit more
about those yeah i'm just often just
right off the top in the very beginning
they're worth watching
out of the two
out of everything it reminds me mostly
of night gallery but a british version
of that
i'd still have to give it to night
gallery for just weirdness though night
gallery was more intense more weird yeah
i found night gallery like creepier real
creepy kind of yeah the girl that finds
it damn that was an evil girl that was
torturing the damn monster and putting
rocks around that was a weird one
remember that one yeah and then the dude
who had to live in the air conditioning
it's like in florida as soon as the air
conditioner was gone it fell apart well
that was based on a lovecraft store yeah
that's cool air that's really that's a
very famous lovecraft story that's been
adapted lots of times right yeah this
one was interesting because i don't
think none of them seem to be like
adaptations of other stories because i
know that they had like another
anthology i think this was also a
british anthology show tales of the
unexpected and i think most of those
were if i'm not mistaken please correct
me if i'm wrong but i'm pretty sure that
most of those were adapted from like
rolled doll stories and i think that
well even like alfred hitchcock presents
and [ __ ] like that in the u.s i think
they adapted like a bunch of rolled doll
stories as well um you know and like
like i said like you know twilight zone
and stuff they adapted like a lot of
stories by like richard matheson and
harlan ellison and you know established
short stories these ones all looked like
at least from what i could determine
we're all like original stories and
we're all kind of like written by some
of the hammer writers and directed by
the hammer directors yeah i'd have to
give a shout out to twilight so probably
one of the best television series of all
time i rewatched twilight zone like
every couple of years like the whole
series
i mean again those were weird some of
them are better than others but you're
gonna get that with any anthology show i
mean some of them were pretty just
generic but some of them were [ __ ]
really weird yeah the thing about this
one uh the thing about hammer house of
horror is that i think it relied less on
twist endings because i feel like tales
of the unexpected or a lot of the stuff
that was based on like roll doll stuff
was um you know kind of like oh there's
like a twist ending and some of these
had twist endings some of them you can
see coming i'm thinking uh in particular
of one called visitor from the grave
which i think i saw that ending coming a
mile away because
that twist has been done a lot of times
but there was one episode in particular
which i'll talk about in a second um
that went in a direction i really was
not expecting so i thought that was kind
of cool but and not all of them had
twists really so i kind of thought that
was good there was a and there's kind of
something for everybody there's witches
there's like satanic cult there's like a
conspiracy theory psychological horror
technique there's doppelgangers there's
a werewolf one you know so there's you
know there's kind of like a weird
surrealist like dream nightmare thing
there's so there's kind of like i said
something for everybody
oh and there's a serial killer one sale
um so yeah so the first one which i
think is one of the ones that you saw uh
is called witching time this one
interestingly uh the witch is played by
patricia quinn probably most famous well
not probably absolutely most famous for
playing magenta in the rocky horror
picture show so uh so she's in this one
and basically what happens is this dude
named david and i guess he's like a
music
like he writes music for movies or
something
and uh so his wife is uh cheating on him
which he suspects but can't prove and it
actually turns out that she is [ __ ]
his psychiatrist or his psychologist
who's played by ian mcculloch who was in
a bunch of lucio folgi movies so again
you know he was a british actor but for
irish scottish i don't remember but he
was uh in a bunch of lucio folgi like in
a bunch of italian horror movies so his
wife's sticking around and uh
like jumping on the psychiatrist dick
now while he's home alone
a very weird thing happens this strange
woman
uh magenta appears in his barn
and claims that she is lucinda jessup
and that she was being burned for a
witch back in 16
and uh somehow used magic to like magic
herself into the future to like escape
uh the flames which neat trick so she is
an actual witch
uh so at this point it's good because
this one wasn't one of my favorites but
i kind of like that that had they
started out with this because i like old
school witch [ __ ] so she turns out to be
like a super evil witch but for a long
time because she can apparently like
appear and disappear because david like
kind of locks her in a room as you would
because at first he thinks she's just a
nut case who turned up in his barn uh
and then he calls somebody else and then
like she's disappeared from the locked
room
so she can kind of like uh disappear and
appear at will
so for a long time nobody else sees her
so everybody else thinks that david is
just like losing his [ __ ] marbles
because he said like for real there's
this witch that like popped up and like
and he can she can like control him and
stuff so so there's that whole situation
uh where this witch is like uh
tormenting him and also
kind of like trying to get him to kill
his unfaithful wife and like burn her at
the stake instead for whatever purpose
but yeah this one was a pretty decent
one like i said cool to see uh patricia
quinn and something else i know she was
in other things but i mean
she's just so
she's magenta to me so it's just like
weird seeing her playing another part
and it's weird because she almost sounds
like she had an american accent in this
and i was just like oh she's irish
though i'm pretty sure
um but yeah it kind of sounded like a
like a thing
now the one with the twist
that i was talking about that i didn't
see coming is the second one and this
one's called the 13th reunion
and this starts out with this woman
named ruth and she's like a journalist
but she works
she works on a newspaper on like the
women's page and she's like really not
happy about it because she's always just
kind of like why do i have to like read
all these stupid fashion shows and [ __ ]
like that i want to write about
something like important
so
because her
editor apparently thinks she is fat even
though she absolutely is not and it's
really weird they should have probably
hired or at least put her in a fat suit
or something because the first part of
this they're like okay well there's this
new weight loss clinic or like a health
farm
and there's been all these weird like um
complaints about it because everybody's
saying that they're super abusive and
there's like but it works apparently but
so they're gonna send this woman ruth
like undercover to like go infiltrate
this health farm
and so but they make all these like that
literally the first thing she walks into
her enters her office and the editor
says you're overweight and i'm like is
she that i mean she had a bulky sweater
on but then when they showed her later
on i'm like she is absolutely maybe she
was like 70s overweight because she was
like super skinny no it's just the 70s i
guess
what i'm saying is you know
it was it's theater you're suspending
disbelief
well because then it bothered me the
whole time i'm like she is absolutely
not fat by any they're pretty definitely
people pretend for a
living but they put her in bulky clothes
at first but then later on she was just
wearing normal [ __ ] she was like
she's like the so-called fat girl from
greece she's obviously not fat she's
just wearing [ __ ] big bulky clothes
yeah
that's just kind of like then they show
her the last scene and she's skinny well
she always looked like that yeah it's
like they were just kind of like punched
her out yeah they were just trying to
make you believe it that's kind of what
they did here
so what ends up happening is that she
infiltrates this uh this health farm or
this weight loss clinic and the first
thing like she goes to this meeting and
there's this dude and he's just berating
this woman like telling her what a fat
cow she is and how her she's disgusting
and all this other kind of stuff
and uh so ruth is just kind of like huh
well this is weird now she ends up
meeting this other dude who is also the
host who's played by the same guy that
played uh dim in a clockwork orange like
i said this is the only other thing i
had seen him into even though he's been
at a [ __ ] ton of stuff but that's
probably what he's most famous for
so
she finds out that like he's he's
allowed because she's not allowed to eat
because they're like all right you fat
pig like you have to eat just like
lettuce and nothing lettuce and
cigarettes that's like the 70s diet and
cocaine um but he's allowed to like eat
all the potatoes he wants and all this
other stuff and they said well they you
know it's different for everybody else
for everybody
um so he's just allowed to eat all this
fattening [ __ ] but then it turns out
that
uh the guy dim his character's name is
ben okay but he dies in a car accident
and after that ruth hooks up with this
kid well like a guy like a young guy
that works at the mortuary and he's like
you know i think that like the two guys
that run the mortuary i think they're
doing some shady [ __ ] like with some of
the bodies that turn up at this mortuary
and um so she's like oh it's a real
story like instead of like all the
stupid weight loss [ __ ] she usually
writes so she is so her she starts
playing like nancy drew around the [ __ ]
and uh trying to find out what these two
dudes are doing with these occasional
bodies that they're spiriting away
somewhere
and um this one was good because this
one
like i said it was it was an adventure
this one um because i had no idea like
where it was going i was just like
what's with this weight loss clinic and
then i thought it was gonna go remember
that creep show episode where they made
them eat those parasites that like could
take all that weight off i thought it
was going to go in that direction that's
not the direction it goes in i just
really was not expecting it i don't
really want to spoil it because i don't
know if a lot of americans have seen
hammer house of horror and shutter just
added it you can also watch it i think
on 2b and pluto for free maybe but
shutter just added it too it's like in
their little series tab but uh so i
don't really want to say like where this
went because i didn't expect it and i
was just kind of like okay fair enough
that that's kind of cool now the third
one i think this was my favorite this
was the one with den home elliott in it
uh this one was called rude awakening
this one i really liked because i really
liked that it was kind of like a
nightmare like all the way through uh
and it had kind of i don't want to say
it had a david lynchian by but it did
kind of have that whole like dream and
you don't really know like what's a
dream and what's reality so dennholm
elliott he plays this dude named norman
and he's like a real estate agent and he
has this office and he has like this hot
secretary
and at the beginning of it like this
dude comes in and says hey i have this
like big property that i want you know
taking off my hands he's just he doesn't
own it or whatever and so norman goes
there and it's like this big it's a
massive like mansion or whatever but
it's like a [ __ ] it's like really in
a horrible like condition
and so
so you kind of established that you
established that this older guy is
having an affair
with his secretary his name is lolly
and she's way younger she's like his
daughter's age maybe his granddaughter's
age i'm not really sure maybe not but um
she looks familiar she gets it behind
her and she's sitting in the desert he
puts her in just grabs her head
and dude
sorry
was funny that wasn't what i looked like
i was massaging he was doing like steven
seagal like he was testing over breast
cancer checking for breast cancer yeah
he's
doing shout outs to the special shiatsu
no no
he started
this isn't even about me i'm not even in
this movie
but yeah so
he also has a wife named emily who he is
kind of planning to get rid of now it's
kind of cool how this one goes on too
because
each time like what ends up happening is
that he goes to this weird house like
out in the middle of nowhere and he's
looking at it and then like i said it's
really creepy and dilapidated or
whatever and then this dumbwaiter thing
opens and like his wife's body falls out
of it and then he keeps hearing these
disembodied voices saying like why did
you kill your wife why did you kill your
wife and he's like what the [ __ ] and
then like he wakes up and that was
actually a nightmare but then it as it
goes on he keeps thinking that he woke
up from a nightmare but every single
subsequent thing also turns out to be a
nightmare and it's like funny because
lolly his secretary looks different like
in every iteration like she has a
different colored hair she has different
colored outfit on like in one iteration
she actually kind of looked like some
[ __ ] xanadu like olivia newton john
like she had like a big blonde afroy
kind of thing and like this crazy
red spandex something that you would
never wear to work like in a million
years but because it was like a dream of
his um you know but he kept it but he
keeps hearing these voices and like
getting phone calls saying like why did
you kill your wife and all this other
stuff and then like you so you don't
actually know what's really going on and
what he's just dreaming uh until the end
and i really really liked this one i
think this one
and spoiler alert the one with peter
cushing uh were my favorite ones i think
those were the two strongest ones and
from the few reviews of this that i saw
that seems to be like the pretty
prevailing attitude although i think
that like i don't know it's kind of all
over the map like which ones people
liked but i think this one and the peter
cushing one um kind of come up as most
people's favorites um the next one is
called growing pains and that one this
one was pretty good that was just like
about a kid who his dad's like a
scientist and he was trying to grow
plants that have protein in them i was
like oh he was way ahead of his time
wasn't he um you know for the third
world like to feed the hungry and
everything like that and his son ends up
just casually walking through his lab
one day and just swallowing a bunch of
[ __ ] that was like in a jar like as one
does uh and it kills him
and so
they adopt another kid like who's the
same age like from an orphanage and the
kid is like super weird and then you
think that it's kind of going in an evil
kid direction which it kind of does
but there's also some supernatural [ __ ]
going on too like with
the the ghost of the first kid so this
one was pretty good too like i said this
one was kind of i've seen other stories
like this so this one wasn't like super
original but you know still worth
watching uh the next one was the house
that bled to death
and that was one where which is a great
title by the way
um that one's like a couple and they
move into this kind of shitty
council house or whatever with their
daughter and i guess there'd been like a
murder there before but they didn't know
that
and then this one had a twist too that
also i didn't see coming um and i
actually kind of liked the twist on this
one again i don't want to spoil it but
all this like supernatural [ __ ] starts
happening like the pipes bust open and
blood comes out and you know just
poltergeisty type [ __ ] uh starts going
on and they start blaming the neighbor
because i guess like the poltergeist
[ __ ] only happens like when the neighbor
is there and all this other stuff um so
yeah this one was pretty good too and
like i said also has a twist at the end
that i didn't really see coming but i
actually did like the twist of this one
the next one is called charlie boy and
this one was kind of like a voodoo e
type story uh had kind of an african
fetish kind of like trilogy of terror
type situation where this couple
they buy uh like at an antique sale or a
state sale or whatever this sort of like
african voodoo fetishy thing and um so
the guy like one night he
jokingly he gets into this road rage
incident like this and this dude he's
like a gangster or whatever and then he
gets so mad about it that he's like man
i wish i could kill that dude or
whatever and then like he stabs the
the statue and then so then like a
voodoo curse is like set into motion uh
so this so it's kind of like a basically
and this one doesn't really have a twist
it kind of just goes on like to its
logical conclusion like you know he's
like hey this voodoo [ __ ] actually works
but you know it ends up kind of like
biting him in the ass in the end so
again that one uh pretty decent the next
one is the one that most people point to
as their favorite and this is easily one
of the standout ones this is called the
silent scream and this has peter cushing
in it
and brian cox
who was in
[ __ ] tons of british stuff i mean he is
super super recognizable and he was in
like from the indiana jones movies stuff
like that so uh so yeah so
brian cox plays this dude named chuck
and he was in prison for two years for
robbery i guess feels like a safe
cracker
and while he was in there peter cushing
who plays this dude named martin
bluewick
like a german fella he has been uh
counseling him and like giving him money
and stuff like that while he's in prison
and so once chuck gets out he goes back
to martin's uh pet shop to thank him
and he's like well okay well i'm gonna
give you a job like until you can get a
better one because i know you got a
prison and everything's rough and ever
and stuff
so he gives him this job apparently
martin has in the back or basement of
his pet shop he's doing these
experiments with wild animals so he has
like panthers and tigers and so i don't
know about tigers but there's like
panthers and all kind of like dangerous
big cats and [ __ ] in there and he's like
i'm trying to condition these animals to
not need cages like to not attack me so
he's basically using like opera and
conditioning type of thing where he
electrocutes the gates or like the you
know the doors and he has also
conditioned them to like only eat even
though he puts food in front of them
like they only eat like when he makes a
certain sound so he's doing like
conditioning
and uh it will probably surprise no one
to know that he also wants to try this
[ __ ] out on people
and um because chuck does something that
he probably shouldn't do he ends up
getting trapped in this
essentially like cage or like a you know
a cell uh and he starts to get
conditioned as well because and then it
turns out too that spoiler alert peter
cushing's character uh who
had told chuck he's like yeah i know all
about you know prison and everything
like that because i was in the
concentration camps turns out he was a
guard not a prisoner so he's like doing
all these experiments with people to
like see if they can be conditioned the
same way that animals can be conditioned
uh using electro electricity and things
like that this one was a really really
good one i mean the acting peter cushing
and brian cox it's really great i think
this is the only thing they did together
but this was and peter cushing this was
pretty late like isn't he's pretty old
in this but the two of them are just
fantastic in this and it's just it's
such a great premise
um and it's just like i don't know i
really like the way this one goes and
this one has a really like nasty ending
and i really didn't expect it to end
that like that like i thought everything
was gonna work itself out uh but it
didn't um so yeah i really like this one
and like i said this one a lot of
reviews that i said were like um that i
saw
said this one you could probably because
you can buy this like on dvd and blu-ray
and [ __ ] like that obviously nowadays um
but a lot of people said this one's like
just worth the price of admission like
all by itself and i think i would agree
with that but like i said this one and
uh rude awakening are easily my
favorites i mean just the acting is
great the premise is great it's just
like [ __ ] great uh the next one
children of the full moon this is a
werewolf one which you'll be able to
figure out pretty uh early on this one
actually stars
diana doors she if you don't know
anything about british culture anything
like that she was like the british
marilyn monroe she was like the blonde
bombshell you know back she looked a lot
like marilyn monroe actually she looked
more like uh what's who's the other one
the uh [ __ ] man ah god damn it what's
her name what's her name i'll take him
no mamie vandoorne maybe she actually
reminds me a little bit about her made
me been doing hotter than [ __ ] monroe
i didn't i didn't see anything in
marilyn monroe maybe van doren had like
bigger boobies yeah she was a lot harder
way bigger
but she yeah so diana doris was kind of
like the she looked a lot like mimi
vandoren in the 50s and then um i didn't
actually recognize her for well i
recognized her face i was like god her
face looks so familiar i mean she was
obviously much much older in this one
and this was actually uh 1980 i think
that was only like four years before she
died but she kind of plays this creepy
old woman there's like this couple and
they're going out i think it's somerset
or whatever and they're going out on
holiday and their car wrecks and they
end up at this like really remote
farmhouse and diana doors plays this
kind of like overly friendly but like
super creepy like matronly woman
and she has this whole gaggle of
children
who she says are not all hers like some
of them are like foster like some of
their step kids and stuff and it's just
the whole situation is just like really
really creepy and you're not entirely
sure what's going on
um but like i said
this one it's not really a twist because
they established pretty early on that
there's some like werewolf action going
on
so
um but i like this at the middle of it
it's almost kind of like they you think
they get away because
uh the the couple are like oh something
bad happened and then you know but then
later the guy wakes up in the hospital
and they're like oh we were just in a
car crash so they for a while they think
the whole werewolf [ __ ] was like a dream
which i thought was kind of cool so
there was like ambiguity for a while
over whether the werewolf [ __ ] really
happened or not but yeah it's definitely
a werewolf story so yeah that was also a
good one the next one is carpathian
eagle
this is a serial killer one uh this is
basically about
all these dudes keep turning up dead
with their hearts cut out um
you know so the cops are just kind of
like okay well serial killer so while
they're investigating they go to this
woman who is
writing a book
about
essentially it was kind of like a
countess bathory type of uh type of
woman like 300 years ago she had cut
like she killed like 107 dudes like
cutting their hearts out so they think
that somebody knew about that
and so they're doing a copycat type
thing like 300 years later even though
it's apparently not a real well-known
story so they so they go to this woman
that's writing a book about it and then
they go to this like oh this older woman
who's like a descendant of the countess
and they're kind of like investigating
all of that situation and um i don't
really want to spoil this one either
although i saw where this was going
about halfway through like i figured out
who the killer was um so i don't know
your mileage may vary i'm not like i
said i'm not going to spoil it but i
figured out who the killer was
now interestingly
on the wikipedia page and everywhere
else they have the 11th episode listed
as visitor from the grave but on shutter
visitor from the grave is the last
episode that's like the 13th one i think
this might have been my least favorite
maybe just because one you could see
where it was going
um
two the woman that played she's like an
american heiress or something and she's
like in the uk
and this dude
breaks into her house like while her
husband is away or her boyfriend
and is say like oh your boyfriend owes
me money or whatever and i'm just gonna
like take it out of your vagina like so
he tries to like rape her and she
straight up straight shoots him in the
face like with a shotgun
and then
she gets like really super hysterical
about it and then just sees the dude
everywhere so like the dude is like
haunting her
um and she's cause she was mentally
unstable to start with
um
pretty much like as soon as you know
that she's like an heiress and has a
[ __ ] ton of money you can pretty much
see and i don't feel bad about spoiling
this one because like i said i've seen a
lot of stories like this um basically
the whole thing was a setup like she
didn't really shoot that dude it was all
and her boyfriend and the dude that she
shot and this psychic and this like in a
quote-unquote indian swami medium they
were all like in on it like to get her
to blow her head off or get committed or
whatever so they could take all her
money but
it's still good i think this was like
but i think it was my least favorite one
one just because it was a little bit
predictable and two because the woman
that played the american heiress was
just like way over the top like with the
hysterics you know what i mean so you
know that's but it was good otherwise
like it had some like creepy [ __ ] going
on two faces of evil these two these
last two were like some of the weirdest
ones two faces of evil is essentially
like a doppelganger story where
there's this family and they're going on
holiday again and they're out in this
car and there's like a rainstorm and
they pick up
this dude that's like wearing a yellow
raincoat and yellow hat like he looks
like the gordon's fisherman and you
can't really and you can't really see
his face and pretty much immediately as
soon as he gets in the car he attacks
the dad um and they run off the road the
car flips over and then everybody's in
the hospital
but
later on like the mom and the kid aren't
really hurt but the dad apparently he
had like some glass from when she like
went into his throat or something so he
can't talk
and then so they take the dad home and
then he starts acting really weird and
like the mom starts becoming convinced
that the dude in the raincoat
and her husband are like had switchblade
or one of them was a doppelganger you
know i mean like the husband looked like
her husband but wasn't really her
husband so
that was because i wasn't really sure i
didn't know that was about doppelgangers
at first so i was just sitting there
going like wait what the [ __ ] is going
on but they they kind of establish it
but it takes a while like for it to know
that it's about doppelgangers but this
one was a pretty good one too although i
think this was like my second least
favorite
um and then the last one although it's
the 11th one if you're watching it on
shutter uh this one's called the mark of
satan and if you're into like
numerology not numerology but like
conspiracy theories or stuff like that
this one is actually pretty good because
this is a dude and
he's um he works in a mortuary and he
becomes obsessed with like there's this
patient that's brought in and i think he
was like a neurosurgeon and he had
apparently tried to
drill into his head with you know with
the drill um to let the devil out or a
demon or something because the girl
tried to dead on damn and filmed it
remember that yeah yeah yeah she took
that ass and [ __ ] drilled it down
through her third eye that was weird
[ __ ] man people were [ __ ] tripping
back in the day yeah i know so man i
don't know when did that happen 70s so
maybe that's where they got the idea of
like for the start of this late 60s yeah
so so he tried to drill into his own
head and he doesn't kill himself right
away but then like the other doctors
like try to save him but they're not
able to and the last thing he says where
he dies is leave my soul alone so the
guy that works at the mortuary becomes
obsessed with this case
and he starts to become obsessed with
the number nine because like if people
say it and he's just like oh my god it
means something number nine yeah that's
what i was thinking that the whole time
i was watching that that [ __ ] and um
yeah and so he so he starts to become
convinced that there's almost kind of
like i don't know if it's so much like
the devil or it's like
the devil in the form of a virus and he
thinks that there's like this conspiracy
like everyone's in on it and they gave
him this evil virus
um to
do something i'm not sure what i'm not
entirely sure what the end game is but
so this dude like he thinks that
there's um weather veins like he every
time he looks up at a weather vein like
he hears like radio static like in his
head like something it's like
communicating with him and stuff so it's
kind of like he has like schizophrenia
or something like that but and then he's
so
so everybody he thinks everybody's in on
this conspiracy to give him this evil
virus for whatever reason because he's
an innocent person or whatever he has
this really horrible mother um who he
ends up killing and you know good
riddance but um and he also has this
woman who lives in his building
and then it ends up like she helps him
hide the body and then this is another
one too where you're not entirely sure
whether he's just like paranoid or
whether there is this cabal
of people like satanist something or
other that are trying to like get into
his brain somehow and getting him to eat
a baby because that's in there too um
you know so it's just
who wouldn't want somebody to eat a baby
but yeah he's trying to like get him to
do that and then it's like halfway
through you're kind of just like he's
like oh no i'm fine now
uh i was just being paranoid i had a i
had a moment and they fixed it but then
you're not entirely sure but yeah so
as i said if you're really into
anthology horror um you know and if
you've watched this because like i said
i feel like maybe a lot of people have
watched it recently because shutter just
added it but if you don't have shutter
but you should get shutter but if you
don't then i think you can watch it on
pluto for free and you might be able to
watch it on tv for free i'm not entirely
sure but these are all like these are
all really good they're all really worth
watching like i said it's like 13
sort of short hammer movies they're i
think the shortest one is like 45
minutes and the longest one is like 53
minutes
um you know like i said some of them are
better than others uh i think that the
silent scream is the best one and the
silent scream and um rude awakening are
like kind of tied for my favorites out
of the series but they're all pretty
decent there was none of them that i
would've been like oh well that was a
waste of time you know what i mean
yeah i would say it was bad on par with
night night gallery yeah so especially
if you like night gallery or anything or
thriller or any of those type of things
or if you like like the amicus
uh movies then you would probably like
really dig this like some of like i know
that some people thought like because i
looked at a lot of the shutter comments
um and it was either kind of like
everybody loved it or there was a couple
that were probably like younger and they
were probably like these are so boring
and slow
um but you know a lot of the stuff from
that era was
they they took a while to like establish
because these are essentially like mini
movies they're like an hour long right
so they need to like do some character
development um and i like that they kind
of did some of them were supernatural
some of them weren't supernatural some
were kind of like surrealism or
dreamlike and some of them were kind of
more prosaic so they kind of like i said
had something for everybody uh kind of
happy that there wasn't a vampire one
have to say there was a werewolf one and
there was a witch one but yeah maybe
even back then vampires are like yeah
we're sick of vampires we're hammer
we're not doing any [ __ ] vampires
okay
that's i know that's kind of our thing
but yeah so
like i said if you look into horror
anthologies then it's definitely worth
checking out uh i'd be interested
because i know we have a lot of british
listeners to know if you guys saw this
when you were kids or you know if you
saw it later on and what you thought
about it like i said everybody
in this oh i forgot to mention too that
the one with the serial killer uh the
carpathian eagle one had an appearance
by a very very young pierce brosnan he
was he was actually kind of one of the
victims he was only in it for like two
minutes or something he had a couple of
lines but i was like watching it i was
like holy [ __ ] that's pierce brosnan but
now i think he was in i think he was in
that british movie wasn't he in the long
good friday but i can't remember if that
came out before this or after this so
this might have been like his first big
like role maybe even though he was only
in it for like two minutes but yeah if
if you know anything about british
cinema or british tv or anything like
that everybody in this is familiar um
and it's just like crazy and even me i'm
not from the uk but it's like i've seen
a lot of the movies and tv from over
there so i recognize pretty much
everybody uh but yeah so
i think i was most excited to see
magenta and see dim because
those are the only times i've seen them
and it was cool to like see them in
something else but yeah definitely uh
check this out it's a lot of fun and uh
let us know what you thought about in
the comments and we will see you guys on
the next movie retrospective
bye